- So where do you see
yourself in five years?
- Honestly, I'd love to
be married with a baby.
Yeah, I mean, figure out
a way to work from home,
and maybe just come into
the office as needed.
(coughing)
- Sounds great.
(laughs uncomfortably)
(energetic music)
- Aww, Allison, you look cute today!
- Thank you!
I think so too.
- Oh, okay.
- Just wanna let you know I
got your email, it looks--
Oh what's wrong?
- Oh, Henry just yelled at me in a meeting
for something I didn't even do,
so, I like, powercried in
the bathroom for 10 minutes,
but now I'm fine.
- Sorry, um...
Toughen up, kid.
(laughter)
- Allison, what's wrong,
why aren't you laughing?
- Oh, it just wasn't very funny.
- Someone needs to bake
herself a sense of humor.
(laughter)
- Hey, uh, would you wanna
get dinner Friday, my treat?
- Oh, like a big group thing?
Like a hangout?
- No, just a date.
- Oh, oh...
I would, but, I've got this um...
- Okay, no pressure.
- We will definitely be together because
he will leave his girlfriend
and we'll be soulmates--
- Gabby, I'm sorry, but you
talk to me about this guy
everyday, you never listen
to any of my advice.
I'm sorry, I can't hear it anymore.
It's not healthy.
- I mean, we can just go
see the movie next week.
- Yeah, oh, I gotta go change my tampon.
Be right back.
- Well that was really fun.
- Yeah, I'll see you later.
- I guess I should walk you to your car?
- No, I don't need you
to walk me to my car.
I'm fine, it's right here.
- But it's not safe.
- It's ok, it's right here.
- But I...
- Chris I'm okay.
- But I, uh--
- Chris, it's literally right here.
- See, I should, I feel like I need to...
- You wanna supervise me getting in?
- I love you?